I just finished the press junket for  this for ghost in the shell' yesterday  and I finally got so tired of being  asked how long it took me to put on my  suit and what am I wear under there I  said I'm sorry do you happen to ask a  man this question I've already cares  about guys that's maybe what it is Yeah  right you don't want to worry about it  you're squeezing into the outfit is hot  right yeah I don't want to think about  Robert Downey getting into retirement  who cares I mean you know I actually  asked him how long it took him to get it  was my gosh I think it's intriguing  especially to men I mean the shoot is  like you're nude but you're not nude you  know yeah that's the random news but I'm  not new yeah and I like that yeah but  it's not use their imagination you  really want to know I love Josh people  go how do you go to the bathroom I'm  like come on is that do people really  need to know that